you shared via social media that you
lost i i not believing this okay 100
pounds crazy crazy and you received such
an outpouring of love and support
how did you how did you do it let's
start there
well it took three years wow that's the
healthy way though i always i call it
determined patience yeah jessica simpson
reveals the secret to her 100 pound
weight loss and guys it's all about
putting in that hard work i work my butt
off
to get in to shape and to like stay on a
health kick earlier this month the 41
year old singer posted this bikini pic
to instagram dishing on her fitness
journey in the caption quote i have
gained and lost 100 pounds three times
so i never thought this moment could or
would happen but i'm finally spring
break and wearing a bikini the mom of
three broke it down into three simple
phrases hard work determination
self-love and admitted all the
commitment to her health resulted in a
good proud cry if you have a goal if you
want to achieve it you have to put
everything you have into it well during
a recent stop by the reel just got
candid about her journey revealing it
took a long time and a lot of focus
i believe in setting small goals for
yourself
because in my life and how i've done it
i mean there's easy ways to throw in
the towel and just feel like it's
impossible
so the small goals for me are what
helped me achieve
the main goal being in a bikini was
never my main goal it may not have been
the main goal but slipping into that
two-piece on her family vacay had the
fashion mogul in her feelings i thought
i was just gonna be in a one-piece so
when i put that two piece on i got super
emotional
and i was like i did this
oh it happened so
it was just like in the moment and i
wanted to share it with everyone because
i was very proud of
myself for doing what
at times felt completely impossible um
and you know i've lost 100 pounds three
times um i definitely gained weight a
lot of weight in my pregnancy back in
january jessica opened up about giving
birth to her third child birdie in 2019
telling bloomberg businessweek that she
was lying on a hospital bed with a case
of bronchitis that had gotten so bad she
had to be on a breathing machine
bertie's oxygen levels were dropping i
couldn't breathe i was
260 pounds she was a very big baby we
were like just take her out doctors were
able to stabilize birdie who was born
via c-section weighing in at 10 pounds
13 ounces i celebrate pregnancy but this
last pregnancy was really hard for me i
don't know if it was because i was older
and hormones and all kinds of stuff
right whoa birdie welcome
of course jess and her husband eric
johnson are also parents to a
nine-year-old daughter maxwell and an
eight-year-old son ace and when e.t sat
down with the pop star back in 2020 she
opened up about the pressure to get back
in shape after pregnancy the body image
pressures they never go away because so
many people
focus on it i mean people think right
now like oh she snapped back i did not
snap back i i wish i just snapped back
but i worked my butt off
to get in to shape and to like stay on a
health kick yeah and the the tummy tucks
were back to back that was after i had
lost
a ton of weight and
um i had skin and like stretch marks
because i had two babies back to back 14
months apart when i get pregnant i blow
up but we listen to what our bodies need
and it's that donut or for
and last year jess told et it's not
about a number it's all about how you
feel
i say throw out the scale i have to rid
myself of like measuring
up to like what weight i should be
because i've had so many people tell me
what weight i need to be and
i think it's really about just
how
how you feel but it doesn't happen
overnight and you have to be patient
with yourself you have to be kind
to yourself uh you have to love yourself
flaws and all like there's rewards in
every day like this is what i did today
let's try it and do it again tomorrow it
doesn't have to be better tomorrow it
can just be like just try